hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is my friend Knox Robinson
returning for his second appearance on
the show Knox is a runner he's the
co-founder of black roses NYC in New
York city-based running group he's an
author he's a writer he's a poet he's a
beautiful man and he's here today to
talk about all things race in America
black lives matter and related subjects
it's a fantastic conversation I love
this guy
I really think you guys are going to
enjoy it so without further ado this is
me and Knox Robinson Knox delighted to
have you here thank you for traveling
many miles to be with be with me today
Matt sure of course so you've been holed
up in Mexico City for a while like nine
weeks or something like that it is yeah
yeah it's it's felt like obviously
considering everything it's felt like a
lifetime so yeah I've been out there for
for three months maybe a little over
three months uh-huh been wild yeah I
thought originally that you were down
there for some kind of you know event or
professional reason but that's not the
case right like you went there when
things started to get hairy in New York
and kind of escaped yeah purposefully
yeah exactly no I mean I had been kind
of watching the news since the end of
last year you're just kind of as a vague
conspiracy theories you're always just
kind of seeing you know or an engaged
citizen uh-huh you're kind of just
seeing the chatter and and and and focus
on things and as it just started to
spiral out of control I was just
thinking about on a couple levels like
the practicalities of my own personal
life you know I have like a small
daughter and if the school shut down my
son what he's 16 what was that gonna be
like and then you know what would the
social situation be like in New York on
that guy infrastructural level so I was
thinking about that and then also once
you just started matching up the lack of
cohesion from the national state and
local level in New York
the triumvirate of Trump Cuomo and and
de Blasio it was kind of time here
Johnny fly I was like why Mexico City
though why not I mean Mexico City is
such an incredible place I've been
spending so much time there more and
more and in addition to being like
empirically great conditions 8,000 feet
altitude or 77 hundred feet altitude
rich culture and history
it just seemed livable right you know
and so I went down there with with my
partner and our daughter and and I've
stayed right so she's like three right
your daughter yeah yeah I've only been
in Mexico City wants it was for a
runner's world event when it was it took
place at a college campus that's in that
newer part of town I don't know what
it's called where there's like lots of
fancy skyscrapers and things like that
sure and my only experience were like
the older part of the city was just
touring you know very quickly over the
course of an afternoon but that's kind
of where you're living right like you're
living right in the center yeah well I'm
living in in quakecon which is you know
an incredibly cultural rich neighborhood
because that's where like Frida Kahlo
and Diego Rivera had lived and had their
studio it's interesting there's a big
though the Whitney Museum had a huge
show about Mexican muralists right
before the pandemic closed things and
one of Rivera's contemporaries Jose
Clemente Orozco was was also included in
the show I'm staying at his place oh wow
so you know my daughter sleeping on this
bed underneath like his sketches and his
feast in art and history yeah except
she's three so yeah but the osmosis of
that well yeah but the result is she's
been like devastating the historic
building with crayons like I looked at
your the table the other day and there's
a hole under his mural sketch is like a
huge mural with her crema ruining this
like historic building like I haven't
owner yet but when I move out like the
bills gonna be instead of respect like
the young mind though like with no with
no reverence for you
the legacy that precedes it yeah I guess
so her imprint sounds cool I mean I wish
she could have been an accountant and
just like with the abacus are doing
something less impact when it comes time
to get the security deposit back it's a
wrap on that right
what is mexico city's response to the
pandemic been like what how does that
compare to what's going on in America
yeah I mean it's been it's been
obviously it's been called out in major
media as problematic but again our news
sources our mainstream media's new
sources you know aren't necessarily
trustworthy and so the presidential spot
though the head of state response from
from am low on and down has been a
little sketchy but I was reading kind of
some some information when I went down
there for the first time and he was just
kind of saying and the response was
saying like we know that like humans
aren't gonna be able to social distance
like ad infinitum there's going to be
like a capacity and once bandwidth has
exceeded people are just gonna rebel
against whatever structure so they were
playing that heavy calculus of waiting
for things to peak and crest and then
apply like heavy social distancing
weather whereas like another kind of
method would be impose social distancing
early on you have more prophylactically
yeah exactly but again that comes with
you know in cultures where they may not
even have like the same concepts of
social liberty yeah on what our civil
liberties rather in terms of Mexican joy
of living the social liberties are
pretty chill so I think he was just
saying like listen this is Mexico we
have a huge sort of like day labor force
and you know public transport and you
know mass populace moving around but
also people are chill so they need
really going for like social distancing
strictures and and as you see whether
it's like New York or Arizona once
people kind of like we're over it
they're over it you know and I think
that even today you know we may be on
the wrong side of history with this
conversation but even in this moment
kind of like you know understanding of
those things has been has been shifting
I mean personally I've been in lockdown
my partner is definitely like by the
book social distancing so we haven't
been kind of like flaunting any
conventions and stuff like right I
definitely been tortured with a
three-year-old I think I think we're not
gonna be able to really be able to
evaluate properly which protocol and
strategy was was best you know for
another 18 to 24 months like the word
this is just a huge experiment in
progress and we're seeing different
cities you know apply different measures
now we're seeing the spikes as a result
of the you know the all the protesting
and all of that you know we're comparing
that to the way things are being done in
Sweden and the goalposts just continue
to move and the information that we're
getting from supposedly you know vetted
sources continues to change and I think
it creates a lot of confusion yeah and
you but that up against people just
getting fatigued of staying at home and
they're like [ __ ] it you know and with
the protests it's sort of like the
floodgates open and now it's very hard
to go back you know we're like well we
kind of did that yeah like we're out in
the world now yeah you know I've noticed
in my own behavior just you know I
picked you up at the hotel we hugged you
know we went and did a an antibody test
just before the podcast were both
negative but you know my I wouldn't have
I probably wouldn't have done that like
two weeks ago sure again sitting here
yeah right and and who knows what's
right or wrong like we're all just
figuring out as we go this is just like
a huge petri dish you know
emotion at the moment and it's
interesting he chose Mexico's like I'm
gonna leave New York and I'm gonna go to
the most population dense city in the
world right for the pandemic yeah
interesting choice yeah I mean that's I
mean I guess if anything that just shows
you how dire like my own right kind of
prescription for drug was gonna be I
mean like you know I definitely but you
know I can't see you being able to exist
anywhere for any long period of time
without some significant urban culture
because that's your lifeblood but yeah
you got a you got to carry it around
with you so I'm definitely like you know
trapping out a little bit I mean I when
I think about the things that I wish I
would
brought with me when I like ran out with
like a duffel bag I did bring like the
USB speaker so it's just been if
anything an incredible time to go back
and like dig into so much culture dig
into so much music and yeah go back to
like all the things that you know you
weren't really able to to unlock in the
fast-paced life that we were living up
until very recently yeah you know this
is this moment of forced repose where
we're all being given an opportunity to
take inventory of our lives what's
working what's not and I myself have
been trying to take advantage of that
like the idea that we're just gonna
return to normal I think would be tragic
like here is this moment where we can
really think more deeply and more
profoundly about what we want our lives
and culture and society to look like
layered on top of that with everything
that we're gonna get into you know makes
this all the more exigent in terms of
you know evaluating our systems and our
individual behavior for sure so let's
get into it I mean I think you know as I
was thinking about having you on I
thought man you know everything that's
happening across America right now is so
you know relevant to Knox's you know
vortex of interest it must be weird for
you to be in Mexico City and be more of
an observer of what's happening rather
than a participant because you've been
talking about this stuff your whole life
right and now here we are in this
unprecedented historic moment and you're
in a completely different country yeah I
mean definitely that that double
consciousness of being a black America
that happens all the time as you know
Michelle Obama said Barack Obama can get
killed going to the gas station so
although I definitely have been thinking
about all these ideas and living through
these ideas my whole life and
experiencing sort of these these
you know kind of cultural waves my whole
life at the same time I was thinking
about like what the actual social
situation was gonna be like in lockdown
in New York it's like a black man in
America and that's when I was like I I'm
not here for that because I know me
going down the street that's just like
you
that's just two dice you've got if you
got caught out and there's a curfew you
being a black man just puts you at a
greater risk then I'm just not yeah I'm
just not like I'm not a I'm not a
stay-at-home black man no that is just
not gonna gonna be gonna be that so I
was like let me take myself out of that
situation before I find myself in that
situation and again none of us knew that
the world was gonna like Spiral in this
way but I just it's been amazing to see
it from a distance and then also when
you think about the interaction with
Mexican culture and black American
culture over 500 years it's super
fascinating so for me I mean I'm
thinking about like John Carlos and
Tommie Smith every day I'm thinking
about Mexico City 1968 Olympics everyday
you know so if we're thinking about
Colin Kaepernick and if we're thinking
about Minneapolis then I'm also thinking
about you know the events of 1968 in
Mexico so yeah it is interesting how
this has brought that into the forefront
of consciousness again and we're seeing
those images of those guys and we're
having discussions about you know what
happened to them in the wake of raising
their fist on the podium sure in 68 and
how their lives really were never the
same after that sure what's also
interesting though is how they got to
that point you know and really been
profoundly affected by this book called
the revolt of the black athlete by dr.
Harry Edwards I heard of the it's
incredible but he was the architect that
worked with students organizing in the
early in the mid-60s around San Jose
State I guess and these are the athletes
that ended up on the Olympic team you
know this is the guy who has
been in Kaepernick's here and really
kind of like given him a lot of a lot of
the political support for his kneeling
protests and and also I guess it was the
University of Minnesota football team
that you know I had a boycott in a
protest just several years ago so this
one individual has been kind of like
situating black American athletics and
athletes in the context of political
realities for since the mid sixties
since I really said when did you write
that book in the early sixties and no I
think it might have been a reflection on
the events of 68 and then he's needed to
update it too so then a new edition came
out in the past year so that's super
fascinating
it's kind of getting a second buzz now
because if you saw that soda brick film
high flying bird
I did yeah so that's the that's the the
thing that's going through in the manila
envelope it's that book that's the book
he's reading at the end the revolt of
the black athletes so saw that film that
was incredible mmm so de Burgh film that
all on a phone right I found showing the
whole thing he had been out of the game
he was not he didn't get enough credit
for that movie if that movie came out
right now yeah I mean yeah and it just
just came out I mean so yeah
everybody goes that film because it's
super incredible and then yeah the book
that is revealed at the end is the
revolt of the black African androids
yeah meanwhile how to be an anti-racist
I think is number one on the New York
Times bestseller list yeah the whole
bestseller this is like white fragility
books I know see change for those
writers sounded part by you know a
genuine desire to learn and expand our
awareness I think and also fueled in
part by
you know white guilt I'm glad you said
it
yeah cuz there's certain things that you
could say that I can't cuz I was I read
that and I was like man white people
sure love to buy books that they don't
ever read yeah cuz I was like that whole
list was like white fragility and I was
like it's it's funny like you know black
folks like we have we see white folks
right we I may be in
I may be the Invisible Man but like
black folks have always had a pretty
knotted visible especially with that
hair come on see no but it's funny to
like go on to message boards those are
scary but like even in the comments
section on social media on Instagram and
see white people talking to each other
it's like real comedy it's just like
porn yeah and just to read like white
comments with each other are real crazy
so the amount of performativity that's
going with white people when like a
white person post the fragility book the
comments are like I got that book I
can't wait to start it this Saturday and
I'm like wow every white person is about
to examine their fragility every future
Saturday it's a weird thing that I think
is new for a lot of white people that
you guys have been living in forever
there's a lot of you know performance
virtue signaling out there for sure but
also a tremendous amount of white
fragility and I you know this is new to
me I posted I did an I did a podcast I
put up a couple days ago with my friend
Adam Skolnick who's white Jewish guy and
it was more of just a discussion about
what's going on right now and I posted a
clip from that on Instagram and it has
like you know 390 comments and and
scrolling through that was a wasn't
awakening my friends know and awakening
all over the map yeah my friend Dom
Thompson black dude friend of mine was
like he chimed in he's like man there's
so much white fragility in this comment
section and then he got like 41 comments
underneath right just off that and yeah
and he's was on the side like man and
everyone's like a lot of like repressed
rage a lot of cheerleading like all over
the place and it was very disorienting
for me as somebody who doesn't court
controversy and as somebody who feels
like I'm I'm talking common sense to
realize that we really are divided as a
country there's a there's a plethora of
perspectives on this issue
it's also supercharged at the moment
yeah that makes me afraid of our ability
to move forward we can talk about
optimism you know as we get into this
but you know that's been an education
for me and I think as a white dude like
trying to figure out how to communicate
around this is is tricky too we were
talking about this on the on the ride
over here like you know knowing like
feeling strongly that I don't want to be
silent and I want to be part of positive
change also being sensitive that it's
really not my place to you know lead the
charge at all you know like I want to
participate but also being very
conscious that this is not my movement
but also conscious that that this is a
problem that whites need to solve like
black people are fine you know it's like
it's the white people that have to
figure their [ __ ] out here and that was
what the clip was about it's like this
is a white problem yeah I was
inflammatory for like how do you think
about this like help me out here man
yeah I was still like laughing about the
you know I'm still laughing about the
white fragility reading it's you know
and I and I may be maybe it's just it
like if you said like black people have
always known it and I'm looking at all
these authors who are writing the book
that's like why are you telling people
about why fragility that's the one thing
we had on and it was you know but that's
man it's disorienting
all the way around in in this moment
that's that's for sure I mean on one
hand it's a white problem but it's all
it's our common culture sure oh so if we
all in our country so you know whether
we're thinking about these divided
States of America or we're thinking
about what our culture our common
culture means on a Newman 'el way you
know in the course of like human history
over the past
you know 401 years then then yeah we all
do have a stake in it yeah and what's
that's what's weird about the tension
about we're so divided it's like it's
weird how evenly we're divided even
though there's all these subcultures and
there may be minorities or whatever it's
really lucked orally split like 53 47 51
49 on Indian given day like on so many
issues right you know and that kind of
pushed me pull you is it is really what
it feels like a battle for hearts and
minds and really I think what we're
seeing like play out in real time in the
comment section I mean it's funny right
now in social media it's not even the
content you post no offense to you new
contents great but like it's really the
works and the comments that's where you
break up that's where you monetize like
brands are like my sponsor and I
sponsored comments just to be clear so
so there's this false dichotomies matter
and then you have a contingent of people
say all lives matter right I think we're
getting better at understanding that you
know that what that's all about
yeah but to say is it is it is it
analogous or not to say this is a white
problem versus this is a human problem
you know are those two things like black
lives matter all lives matter white
problem problem with humanity like how
do those things line up well these are
all like tags right these are all like
linguistic cues that kind of redirect
the listeners attention so if their dog
whistles right yeah in their respective
way yeah right and not necessarily you
know laden with the image the the the
energy of dog whistles that say the
president uses but in terms of the
frequency that certain people pick up
it's definitely a valid idea so when
you're thinking about what might
constitute a white problem I mean you
know okay white people got a problem
but redirecting the attention to white
people to own it or to have ownership of
it and to again work at solving at work
on dismantling the problem that's like
an interesting redirect that's a crucial
redirect you know like in an empathetic
you obviously like black people's
problems everybody's problem yeah but
the way the way that's set up you know
if you if you kind of like personalize
it just to black folks then you're gonna
like lose out on a lot of people feeling
infested in or having even any agency I
mean that's that's what's weird I mean
whether like whether there's like social
justice warriors or people who are like
recalcitrant and don't you know really
want to like engage with these issues at
all there has been like a real like
neck-snapping Li Swift realization it
feels like on on the part of a lot of
white people to like jump into this
head-on you know what I mean and it
might be it's that wrongheaded or even
if it's well intentioned or no I mean no
I mean well-intentioned like at this
point we're taking it you know I mean
but like how are we challenge a
challenge challenging sure and
channeling it in in a way that's kind of
like you know moving moving forward you
know like everybody loves moon shots you
know but moon shots don't really exist
right it's really the progress of
incremental gains marginal gains that
really brings us progress but this
situation right here might be one of
those once-in-a-lifetime moon shots yeah
you know where people really being
accelerated through so much you know
there is that sense that we have an
opening now that we haven't seen in our
lifetime yeah and I think it would be
tragic if we weren't able to figure out
you know how to put that energy into you
know the right
Avenue to make those changes yeah and I
think part of it is is you know my
learning curve here has been really
trying to understand the systemic aspect
of this I went and rewatched 13th the
other night with my family and it's just
so powerful like it it really
contextualizes and explains and analyzes
the systemic nature of this in a way
that makes it you know impossible to
avert your glance right when you look at
Alec and the CCA and the way that the
prison infrastructure is set up and the
lobbying efforts and our whole political
system being geared towards you know
these tectonic plates moving such that
black people are disproportionately
incarcerated and penalized it's
impossible to not understand that we
need you know ground-up change like
really fundamental systemic changes in
how we're operating yeah
and that has to that has to be a
conversation I mean like there's you
know it's great to have an electoral
focus but that process is fraught
obviously as the last presidential
several presidential elections as shown
but also you know there needs to be a
community conversation you know rather
than these things are hot-button issues
that are gonna get resolved at a City
Council zoom meeting you know there
needs to be sort of like a real
simpatico energy where everybody is sort
of conversing in these ideas for
starters mm-hmm you know but I feel like
that's happening yeah yeah so then
what's the next step like how do we so
that we're having the conversation yeah
yeah I mean so we're having the
conversation and you know it's wild I
mean it's already things are so
accelerated that right now like downtown
Seattle is like an autonomous cell and
you know people are on flat-bottomed
boats on Lake Havasu just doing
doughnuts right living their life so the
next step is
remains to be seen but I've really kind
of surprisingly just going back to two
older models and I'm finding those are
really resonating so you know it's
interesting to think about by older what
do you mean by it's interesting to see
what like what people are saying in the
60s and 70s you know and we've kind of
glamorized these figures and made him
into posters and t-shirts and and and
biopics but going back and what were the
panthers talking about you know going
back and really looking like what was
the social flux of the 60s and 70s
trying to push forward and and those
things how did they get lost in the late
70s and 80s and what are all those
forces so you know there are some new
models of being right now but I think
that there's also a lot to kind of
uncover and rediscover and what was kind
of set down a couple of generations ago
yeah that was the other thing about 13th
that made me you know made me realize
that there's quite a bit of revisionist
history when it comes to the Panthers
and Angela Davis and Malcolm X and even
Martin Luther King what were taught in
school or led to led to believe and
understand isn't quite the reality of
how that all went down yeah I mean and
and why not right I mean if if we were
choosing between Barack Obama and a guy
who in 1982 or 1983 voted against the
establishment of Martin Luther King jr.
as a holiday when he was Senator of
Arizona that was justice you know a
couple decades ago you know and and rest
in peace John John became but it it
really is interesting that like we don't
even have like a clear picture of King
and he's like got a statue on stamps
yeah you know I mean so definitely
understanding King's legacy and Malcolm
X's legacy and the legacy of that pen I
mean it's amazing to see Angela Davis so
active right and I'm looking on
Instagram and she's like every other
posters everywhere I was like this
hydrate yeah yeah she's probably your
213 13th when she comes into the
courtroom with her big afro yeah like
it's just it's so powerful yeah you know
yeah I mean really and and and you know
maybe I'll keep redirecting the combo to
talk about people's reading lists but
you could just have like a reading list
of the women you know like women in the
early 70s black women of the early 70s
who are coming out of the Panther
movement you know I mean so yeah we know
Angela Davis but I mean asada Shakur's
autobiography is essential reading
Elaine brown you know Ericka Huggins
like all these Kathleen cleaver all
these incredibly storied women and and
had wildly rich lives whether you know
they were you know political actors or
militants or you know freedom fighters
you know who are still around today
super fascinating so we could just reset
the whole New York Times list right now
and put like a sadhus on spire be at the
top well give me a reading list I'll put
it in the show house
okay okay when you were first on the
podcast I was like a couple years ago
two years ago we went through your your
whole story and people who are newer to
the show I encourage you to go back and
listen to that I thought that was a
really great conversation but you know
one of the one of the seminal kind of
moments in your life was being a student
under Maya Angelou you told these
beautiful stories about what that
experience was like I'm curious I would
suspect that you know her words and her
kind of I don't know if mentorship is
too strong a word but her presence in
your life must you know be percolating
of the surface right now yeah yeah I
think about it all the time and she was
such a heavy presence that I wait I wish
it was different you know it's like you
know centers you can't choose your
mentors you know you wish she'd shown up
for that dinner at her house oh gosh I
mean I just you know like it's
interesting to think that she gave the
inaugural poem
at the first Clinton inauguration so
like whatever our feelings about the
Clinton presidency to think that dr.
Angela was this presence on the National
Mall that cold morning in January of I
guess 93 yeah I mean I remember reading
that poem on the pulse of morning as a
high school student and I guess at that
time I thought I was going to you know
study at Wake Forest University I wasn't
really putting the pieces together and
so now even that poem on the pulse of
mourning kind of gone back and like
started to unpack it and it is very like
90s
identity politics and diversity and
bringing people together and if you have
any sort of like hand-wringing
ambivalence about that now maybe it's
just the result of how hardened we've
become recently and how bitter and sour
we've been we've become you know if
we're kind of reading these things and
be like what is she talking about maybe
it's actually you know worthy of a
second look mm-hmm
you know because really dr. angela was
just a vessel of so many experiences and
so many voices you know I was reflecting
recently talking to somebody about it
and they say John Milton was the last
person to have ever read anything on the
planet I mean read have read everything
yeah everything that had been written
and you know I'm like right brother he
learned in the libraries at Timbuktu
yeah but you know as far as a white guy
he had read what white people had put
down a bigot that's what dr. Angelou was
like though she was just like carried
within her guesses the the phrasing goes
multitudes you know I guess as
Wordsworth would say like you know she
really had that and it was just like
spilling out of her
ideally Etta at every occasion so yeah
I'm definitely thinking about her and
her legacy at this at this time
yeah who are the poets right now that
you think are speaking to culture in a
profound way
you know honestly
quarantines been an increasing an
amazing time to reflect on that and you
know there's this poet I'm a writer you
know so you're envious of other writers
um but uh but I
those are just my own appetites you know
but there's this person Dane Smith who
has written this incredible book called
homie I'd been I as I was leaving the
house from Brooklyn to go to Mexico City
I took four or five books with me and
you know this writer is not only putting
down some really lacerating poetry early
on in their career but they're in
Minneapolis like they're from
Minneapolis and so dane Smith is like
walking around Minneapolis kind of like
document on day one I was like wait
my favorite poet like the most essential
poet you know working right now is on
the ground with a mask on documenting
and like getting resources out to people
and so that's the kind of responsibility
that I think if artists certain writers
do have any responsibility at all I
think that's sort of what my vein is
when you're kind of looking at writers
kind of coming out of a Latin American
tradition or like a black American
tradition it's not just I'm graduating
from an MFA program and I'm like writing
my carefully sculpted verses over here
in my Garret apartment at an artist
colony but you know I'm an omnivore and
I'm working on poetry and essays and
book reviews and you know I mean we know
lengths and hues as a poet but if you
think about the buddy flick of Langston
Hughes and Zora Neale Hurston driving
around the American South writing
stories of like regular people's lives
and filing them as dispatches to
gazettes back up in the north that's
kind of like yeah you know that's that's
a that's the work of a writer you know
and so to think that an incredible poet
is there active on the ground you know
kind of documenting the the wildness in
in Minneapolis
yeah as a writer yourself have you been
putting your thoughts down like how are
you approaching this as a creative
person yeah um it's it's it's tough
because you really want to open your
aperture like as wide as you can and
just record everything and remember
everything you know I guess almost in
the way did you think like the earliest
cameras operated before her before is
like a microchip thing if you kind of
just think about the actual crude
mechanics of a light box capturing an
image and preserving and on film or
paper you know is sort of like what the
work of a writer is but especially in
the wake of the Amada arbre killing it's
it's rather poignant ly reset for me my
own relationship with writing my own
responsibilities with writing and so
yeah I've really been doing personal
work thinking about the murder of a
Matar Barry mm-hmm
specifically as a runner that was so
impactful to so many of us obviously in
running culture but obviously around the
world but yeah it's something I can't
shake and so I've been doing a lot of
writing like poetry actually or just
writing on that to think long term like
what what would I have to share and
contribute that would sort of connect
with that guy's life you know well let's
talk about a mod I mean that one is of
particular you know pertinence because
you're a runner right and you read this
article that was in runners world
recently where you were quoted and you
said in some ways I can't escape the
sense that a mod Arbor II was killed
because he was running because he was
that literal embodiment of our freedom
that's obviously still so threatening to
many people in this country yeah I mean
I love to be wrong I love to kind of
like meditate that idea away or like age
that idea away or or or right that idea
away but
I I can't shake it and you know sit back
and watch this trial these trials and
you know see what happens over the
course of due process but I just can't
stop thinking about the dramaturgy or
the theatric the staging of of those
last minutes you know and I think what
it was when the video first came out
obviously it was it's devastating to
watch but uh you know the work is to
expand your aperture so like how much
can you take in how much can you hold
you know it's not just about Milton and
dr. Angela reading a bunch of books but
like how much can you actually hold and
[Music]
I've been I've been black my whole life
right so and i and i'm and i'm well
familiar with extrajudicial killings of
black American men in the United States
I was seeing a runner and I can't I
can't get over like the way his body
moved as a runner on that film in the
last moments it's something that like I
think every runner relates to right if
you have a body or a runner and so if
you're a runner than you're relating to
a Matar beret because it just looked
like it just looked like he was trying
to like continue running you know we you
know we were going down the sidewalk and
like someone's not paying attention you
know what they're Dotson or you know or
someone's veering and you're just kind
of like your focus on suspending your
right your doesn't like that I just
can't stop replaying that image of him
just at those last moments when he just
goes to the right I just Joey his hips
cut in the knees and I was like wow
that's my body you know
and
I'm kind of been exploring that and
riding around that and kind of thinking
about starting there and then moving out
to to think about the messages that is
his life and his legacy kind of hold for
us
yeah I've said this before but you know
as a runner myself I've run and you know
tons of cities all over the world never
once has it ever occurred to me that I
might be in jeopardy or that my life but
might be threatened by strapping on a
pair of running shoes and leaving
whatever hotel I'm in to go explore City
I've never been in before but you know
as black American and as a runner and
also as somebody who's incredibly
well-traveled you've been all over the
world you get to you have this
incredible life where you get to spread
the culture of running wherever you go
like I don't know how that works but
like you cool [ __ ] life obviously you
have a different relationship to that
like that is something that you have to
think about so you know help me
understand you know the psychology of
that like when you're going out to run
like what goes through your mind and you
know what do you have to do to make sure
that you're safe like what is that that
experience that's relatable to you know
every black American who wants to go run
yeah I mean it's it's actually it's it's
actually super complicated because you
know we're in a running boom and so a
lot of people are getting into running
now and so in addition to all the other
challenges of getting into running your
body rebelling against you where do you
like how do you do it like it's the most
simple thing that we have in the human
toolkit but like how do you get started
but I've been talking to like a lot of
brothers a lot of brothers and sisters
who have been doing it our whole lives
or like whoever school-aged athletes and
I think a lot of us actually have like a
different relationship with it then has
been reported in the media and I think
that a lot of us are so proud to be
runners are so proud to do it that it's
such like an inviolable piece of our
identity that when we go out to a run
it's it's like
it's like such a symbol of pride you
know it feels you know like an example
of like a physical example of black
excellence I mean the way you feel you
know the way you feel when you have a
good run you know I think up for a lot
of us is actually tied to feeling good
to be black you know or like kind of
residing in in these bodies that were
blessed with so I don't I don't have
like a fraught relationship with going
out for a run I mean are there sort of I
mean obviously I can give you like a
litany of racist experiences that I've
had run it read like well if you're
gonna do that then you should wear a
t-shirt with a university name on it or
something some some kind of signal and
I'm a safe person running hard enough
like you can line up excuses but if like
I gotta put on an Ivy League shirt to go
for a run I might take up ceramics or
like some other kind you don't think
about that no no no no yeah I mean I and
you put the black roses stuff on yeah
yeah I mean if I've really got a flash
on it but I honestly think that that in
recent years as I've thought more about
why it as I run or like what it means or
what is the experience I've come to
understand that like you know honestly
the the black body moving through space
is such a wild image to people and when
you're a kid try not to get cut from the
track team if you're trying to like not
finish last in the two-mile you ain't
thinking about you're thinking about
like you don't want to let down John
Carlos and Tommie Smith yeah like I
can't finish last cuz then what would
Edward Moses think but you know now I'm
thinking about it and I just see that
like the reactions that people have when
I run by whether I'm in Brooklyn and
bed-stuy if I'm in a black neighborhood
or if I'm in a you know in a white
neighborhood or or in a different
country just I feel that the image of
like a black
and running is one of the most sudden
and visually arresting images that
people might be confronted with that's
not my idea that's just what I'm seeing
and experiencing you know and it's like
why is that triggering why are like
people almost hitting their car I mean
this is like if you run in if you're
training if you run 100 miles a week
that's a lot of people you're asking a
lot of you see a lot of people and so
there's a constant sort of like stop and
stare and sometimes in your vanity you
know someone's checking you out then you
feeling good look like that I don't run
like that guy you know it's like okay
quick take bar I'm gonna cross the
street yeah well yeah I mean you know
when you're fit you're faster than them
so what's weird sorry interrupt but like
what's weird is that you know look
running is dominated by by blacks and
african-americans across the board from
the hundred meters all the way up right
like at the highest level at the elite
level and historically it's rooted in
black culture and African culture but in
America it's sort of this white thing
right which is a strange it's like you
know we think of it we don't think of it
in terms of its ancestral roots yeah I
mean it's elite level yeah I know and I
think that you know lately I just sound
embarrassing like old like curmudgeon D
Marxist or something like that but I
think in terms of like a late capitalist
critique of what happened in in the
running boom coming out of the 70s and
80s you know it really was running
popular running was reduced down to this
idea of like this is something that rich
white guys do and so I have to keep
resetting cuz a lot of us don't even
think that like I've talked to brothers
around the way and we're like this is
like what I do
this is cool so when we joked you know
in our first kind of conversation
together I just grew up that way not
only do I think that that's quaint but
also I'm keep going back to bring
something of that into the present day
and reckon and suggest that you
far from these articles about like
running has always been wide or like
jogging has always been a white sport I
don't really write you grew up your dad
would go to the 10ks and like joke
around with his buddies you're gonna the
culture that you grew up in but one of
the things I love that you do on
Instagram is you'll find old ads from
like the 70s from running magazines yeah
stuff like that and you'll you'll show
them and you you see the sort of
historical you know chronicle of like
how running was portrayed to the public
you serve like the latest pair of shoes
or running shorts and stuff like [ __ ]
and it's super fascinating yeah see how
it's being depicted right well of course
like you know America loves using black
people and black culture is like
marketing forces so even in this the
Michael spino book inner inner running
right or beyond jogging like this super
esoteric 70s kind of cult book about
jogging they had a brother on the cover
and so when I met Mike spino I was like
yeah you were coming at Esalen Institute
you put a black dude on the cover of
this mystical book about running he's
like that's John Carlos he wasn't happy
about that so it's John Carlos but but
yeah so I my understanding of it is that
there's just always been that kind of
representation all the way along until
you know maybe 80s and 90s yeah and I
look back at my training logs or when
you look back at you know the magazines
of the day there wasn't really kind of
any representation or diversity but it
was happening you know the conversations
were there again it's weird to keep
referring to Instagram but I follow some
of these high school heroes or these
guys that I would follow America's best
in the 90s Bob Kennedy
Todd Williams and on Instagram and now
it's kind of cool to see how your
legends ended up man this dude Bob
Kennedy he's from Indiana
he's Indiana like born and bred that was
just like his thing he posted this thing
the other day talking about Steve home
and Steve Holman was this black dude who
was America's best miler you know
or less the best smiler in the mid-90s
when I was kind of coming up and
whatever happened with the Olympic
schedule of every 40 he never never won
a gold or anything like that but it
definitely was that guy cover of runners
world whatever handsome and man just
last week Bob Kennedy posted this
anecdote about riding around with Steve
Holman at a track meet in Los Angeles in
the 90s and like the discrimination that
like Steve Holman was getting coming out
of the hotel and people checking IDs and
it was so crazy to hear about a story of
my heroes in 1994 experiencing something
that I was struggling with as a young
runner at the same time and to know that
like Bob Holman and and and and you know
these these athletes were experiencing
this but that it was also that
conversation Steve Holman and Bob
Kennedy were having this conversation
and Holman saying to Kennedy like you
know yeah this is like my reality and if
you're not part of the solution you're
part of the problem and that's and your
sense was that somebody like that must
must must have transcended that like he
can't be having to deal with the stuff
that I'm having to deal with well you
know it never even got that far he's on
the cover of the magazine and he's got
like a you know winning smile and you're
looking at his times you know you're not
kind of looking at to him for like
lessons of like perseverance you know on
a cultural level on a political level so
honestly kind of broke me a little bit
to read this story of these guys who
were young and pursuing their dreams you
know and and I and I and that's what I
am personally sort of obsessed with you
know like when we're thinking about
black Americans representing the United
States on an international level or just
walking down the street and representing
America you know what does that mean I
mean so we know it's easy to think about
John Carlos and Tommie Smith on the
podium in 1968 winning gold medals and
in the 200 but
what did it mean for Ted Corbett to
represent the United States in the
marathon as a black mare as a black man
in America at the 1956 Games in Helsinki
you know so what was his life like if if
Brown versus Board of Ed was early 50s
right and then Emmett Till Emmett Till's
ghastly murder and an appearance on the
cover of magazine was 55 54 55 and then
Ted Corbett is like wearing the USA
singlet in the marathon you know in 1956
in Helsinki what was his life like I
mean PSA about Ted corvid just really
it's tough to think about running being
always a white man's sport if this guy
was the founding president of New York
Road Runners if this man was the
architect behind the five borough New
York City Marathon course that's
celebrating its 50th anniversary this
year I mean a superlative American Ted
Corbett yeah but I really don't know his
story like that story is being told we
need that on the New York Times
bestseller this but I mean this guy had
the longest streak of sub three our
performances at Boston I mean the guy is
like nine like nineteen like just
whatever and was active up into his 80s
just an incredible ambassador for the
sport clean eating and you know like
like he's what he's one of those guys
you read about like an in the you know
sadly short Black History Month this guy
in addition to all these other exploits
also invented the course measurement
system that's used on bicycles to
measure you know that USATF we used to
like measure courses empirically so this
is like a wild American interesting note
about Ted Corbett he was also a member
of the New York Pioneer Club and the New
York Pioneer Club was America's first
integrated sports club that
yeah integrated in the the decade before
Jackie Robinson integrated major league
baseball so
this kind of legacy of a multicultural
participation of black American
representation in athletics is is
something that is definitely up for
revision for sure mm-hmm
one of your big mantras is and we talked
about this last time is you know running
is an act of rebellion right so now in
light of current events like how do you
contextualize that statement like how
does that apply towards you know your
perspective and the role of advocacy
around what we've seen unfold
you know honestly you know in a
difficult way in a quiet way thinking
about I'm RR Bray's last day you know is
25 and would what job here's a quarter
life crisis he's 25 you know think about
what we were doing when we were 25 or
what people are doing figuring out your
life like you're letting go of you know
the ideals you had of who you were as a
teenager in high school and thinking
about what it means to be an adult and
man instead of sitting around on the
couch like smoking weed you know what I
mean being depressed like the dude put
on his you know not to say he was
sitting around being depressive or
whatever but I just think all of us you
hit that those stages in your life where
you need to figure it out and we know
that you can figure it out through
running and I can't get over the sense
that like like all of us like all
runners it's a vehicle for us to see
goals in the future it's a vehicle for
us to it's to see you know to imagine
and so I keep thinking that
well that's rebellion right because it's
easier for us if we're just gonna be
like a digit it's easy for us if our
politicians are just going to want us to
not show up to the polls if you know
companies just take us for granted that
we're gonna consume whatever food they
put in a package on the shelf you know
that we're not gonna patronize our own
establishment that have like been on
this corner for twenty or thirty years
in a box store can come and replace it
so anytime we're not doing that anytime
we're reinvesting in like the human
community and our own communities and
we're circulating our dollars in our
communities that's rebellion in this
kind of like late-stage capitalist death
row that were we're locked in right now
you know yeah
and then enna Marbury was doing that and
the idea that yeah black man triggering
freedom triggering but also that's just
a symbol of freedom and then I'm agent C
yeah like I actually cannot you know
can't get my car out of shop I can't
change this school loan bill today you
know I can't kind of like you know
changed climate today but like what can
I do today you know and and a run might
not even figure any of that stuff out
but a run might be literally and
figuratively the first steps to figuring
some of those things out yeah well
there's running to something and then
there's running from something
yeah right so running from the cops
that's its own form of rebellion I guess
rights on Fitness winning two to
something implies you know sort of self
investment positive change like I'm
looking for answers I'm grappling with
you know identity yeah I mean so when
people say that yeah running is like a
oh I thing I mean the idea of running is
so deeply bound up in the story of black
Americans that it's it's such a it's
such a metaphor for us which is why I
like preachers talk about it in the
pulpit which is why you know rappers
kind of like reach for it as a metaphor
in their verses so it it's interesting
to kind of restore it and situate it to
look at the ways in which its I could
profound the American thing
and and I think interestingly we're also
seeing a moment in which we're realizing
that things that again like you you
brought up revision you know our own
revisionist history you know there are
certain things that fell out side of the
Canon of euro-american cultural values
you know like one of the things about
white supremacy is that it's so
predicated on this narrow idea I mean
it's a totally concocted fabricated idea
right like what's a white person like
that it also necessarily excluded all
other forms of supremacy all other forms
of culture and existence and so from the
very beginning of this culture of this
countries you know birth so many of
these practices that black Americans
were engaged in were kind of excluded
from the narrative so fabric arts might
be considered making clothes you know
and African hair art you know hair
braiding that we brought with us from
from Africa might just you know not only
be considered hair braiding but was so
threatening on like you know the the
slave plantation system that even that
was sort of forbidden you know so the
things that we were practicing during
African enslavement and then you know in
the in the decades since we're sort of
excluded from the narrative of what
could be art and what could be
creativity and what can be expression
and so this is a bit of a leap but I
think where I'm at right now is like
looking at running as as expression you
know like along the lines of dance you
know like the movement as expression and
movement as an art you know it's it's a
good
okay to call it a sport it's okay to
celebrated the Olympics and put a label
on it but when you're calling it sport
it's able to kind of push it over to the
side and be like that's something that
those folks do but what if we're like
looking at the movement arts next to the
visual arts next to the sonic arts you
know and so I kind of I'm thinking about
running now in the context of sculpture
in the context of like you know Miles
Davis's work in the context of
meditation practice rather than just
kind of like you know doing quarters on
the track so yeah I mean there's a there
is a beauty and a poetry to that and
there are certainly performances that
stand out as examples of that like
whether it's Edwin Moses you know
hurdling or Usain Bolt running 100-meter
dash or coach Oggy you know breaking the
two-hour mark like those those are
pieces of performance art yeah
undoubtedly and when you're you know
kind of recounting these various art
forms you know I can't help but think
about how music is distinct from that
like when when certain art forms
percolated up that did resonate with
white culture they were immediately
appropriated and and repackaged in a
different way so anytime like something
kind of corrupt oh oh I like that
actually that might be something like
let me grab that and I'll take that and
I'll present it to the public in a kind
of mainstream way that's digestible for
them yeah I mean you kind of grow up
knowing that as a black person so that's
the trope of Elvis and all yeah but but
I'm seeing it like all over the place
now you know not only in the work that
you know maybe even I've been doing in
running culture for the past ten years
to see how you know that along with the
efforts of a small group of people
working in urban running has shifted
marketing campaigns of multinational
corporations yeah
that's your fault so yeah definitely
ancestry it's cool to have like a bridge
runners yeah team now ready and stuff
like that I mean it's like black roses
like last time you we did the PI I
thought like I'm gonna ask him for a
black roses Jersey I was like no I can't
I cannot unless I'm part of the team
because I know you don't give those out
right you know it's like you got to be
in the deal yeah I'm trying to hold on
to that you know or and then you know
like Jessica Simpson just like sell it
and like produce it in a sweat shop and
they get rich or whatever but yeah for
now
it's is that kind of idea but yeah for
its wild to have watched brands I mean
people just don't know like you know nod
to the the articles about like running
has been a white thing there was just
like no black people on the pages and oh
you go through the page of or running
ads and it's just like you think it's
only black people if you know if you
were to judge running you know by its
ads you would think only black people do
it cuz Eveleigh marketed their using
using black folks now you know but I I'm
not even kind of like yeah it's you got
to look outside of running for
inspiration to kind of like figure out
your way forward with running and and in
this quarantine time it's been wild to
just kind of again I'm on so many
different like IG lives like it's like
going back to school you know and so
I've been seeing really fascinating
conversations with you know black
ceramicists and looking at the the
connections between you know pottery and
and running or you know I thought about
coming and rappin to you about this but
even the tradition of barbecue in black
culture you know is super fascinating
and to look at the ways in which that's
been gentrified you know I was watching
this there's a super fascinating
barbecue expert named Howard Conyers
think is his name and he's from South
Carolina lives in New Orleans down I'm
so impacted by listen to this guy speak
first of all he's literally a rocket
scientist he's gone and works in a jet
propulsion engine lab or whatever but
he's also
a master at barbecue and the historical
research that he's doing to show that
like Africans were introducing pit
barbecue techniques in 16th century
Mexico Wow like Mexicans are gonna be
mad when I'm back in Mexico like you
think black people invented barbacoa and
I know that's like if you know you're
Pro black I don't think we like knots is
really Pro black but like you know
you're Pro black when you walk around
Mexico like we invented shout out to all
my peoples in Mexico like respect to the
cuisine but I'm really looking at the
ways in which even our own practices
that we've been doing here
in the Americas has just been kind of
like subsumed by the dominant culture
hair-braiding for instance obviously
just a symbol of of black elegance and
communication that we brought with us
from africa bo Derek is like a classic
example of cornrows kind of going crazy
iconic yeah it's tough to be mad at Bo
Derek you know I mean like you know if
you want to like like rail against white
people and Bo Derek's up there with you
know right aids on it's like you got to
be of a certain age though that movie
ten well I mean again though but it's
just wild to see the ways in which like
in running the white women have
appropriated African hairstyles or
african-american hairstyles and and
sometimes not even understanding I've
seen folks call it race braiding and I
was like wow you know not only are you
kind of like really co-opting these kind
of super rich cultural expressions from
black women in America who are paying
the cost for that who are you know
suffering from unfair and discriminatory
hiring practices and pay practices you
know not just because their hair but
because of who they are but to kind of
just like take wholesale black
hairstyles and then just like use that
as like your lucky hair do for your
marathon is is
is offensive you know and is is cultural
appropriation so even in running which
is simple just lacing up and going down
the road is is is rife with cultural
appropriation that bike that is worthy
of investigation for sure well every art
form every trend is built upon the
legacy of some pre-existing form right
so you know if you extrapolate that
argument everything is appropriation so
at what point does the appropriation or
the nod to the forebears you know become
inappropriate and like what is the
responsible ethical way to you know
basically embrace multiculturalism like
I think that's a that's like an area
where a lot of people don't know where
where the ground is farm yeah yeah I
think I think um and it's not sexy but
it really is a question of attribution
and respect and so now and in these days
when people are talking about the phrase
you know do the work knowing sort of you
know you don't want to be a nerd like me
I think kind of just be like making all
these connections but you know you
really do have to understand you brought
up the example of Elvis I mean kind of
taking in rhythm and blues music and
stripping away all that's labeling and
then repackaging it for something that
you want to market in a different kind
of way that's I think probably where the
disconnect is you know so if we're
understanding that Picasso and George
Brock we're getting was we're getting so
much influence from African sculpture
you know when they were working at that
time then we're understanding Picasso a
little bit more and we're also
problematizing our sense of of what
geniuses rather than thinking this is
like the greatest artists of all time
looking at Picasso as a link in the
chain and someone who you might put his
work up as museums are doing now his
work up next to the work of faith
Ringgold you know like how artists can
not only be just contemporaries in the
studio or at a moment in time but also
thematic yeah and cultural
contemporaries and in cultural
conversation juxtaposing those against
the
influences yeah for sure so I think it's
again they always say it's a it's a
question of influences you know and so I
think that when we're respecting where
we're when we're respecting our
inspirations when we when we're
acknowledging our inspirations from from
whence they came then I think that
that's a huge step towards kind of like
again dismantling some of these white
supremacist practices like cultural
appropriation so in a very practical
sense if there's a woman who wants to
you know cornrow her hair for her
marathon yeah how is she supposed to
provide that attribution in a respectful
way well you know I mean might be
economics right you might want to pay a
black woman to do it you know rather
than say like you know if this is how
black women in our communities make
their living with Hair Braiding salons
let's patronize those businesses and
give credit to that like the idea that
like this is high braided my hair in
high school you know and so this is what
I'm gonna do that that's not exactly the
same thing now it should be said that
like women around the world have always
braided their hair in intricate fashion
and so some braiding techniques coming
out of Scandinavia culturally
demonstrable so I'm not trying to take
it and legislate yeah of this but you
know and also I think that taking pause
and thinking how other people might feel
you know is is not only one of the calls
to action for this moment that that
hopefully will go forward but I think
that that's like the work we need to do
now so you know really think how do I
make space for other people how do I
make other people feel comfortable you
know again to say and running or
something like that like how do we
create a more just space and and in our
in our communities yeah
I'm interested in in kind of what unity
and Ally ship looks like to you like I'm
you know just sitting here thinking I'm
a white dude you know I'm privileged I
come from a certain background we're in
this moment and I really want to be as
open as possible and as teachable as
possible
I want to fully understand the breadth
and the depth of what we're contending
with right here and I want to be an ally
and I'm very you know I find myself
feeling cautious or somewhat paralytic
around what to say and what to do for
fear of miss stepping in a culture in
which you know a slight misstep on
Instagram or in public is met with you
know we were talking about before and
not that I really you know care that
much about any of that I really what I
want to what I do care about is like
getting this right I'm I'm interested in
and you know what that looks like from
somebody of your perspective that's
that's an interesting thing and I think
that's something that a lot of us are
thinking about um and one of the things
about double consciousness is is that I
wasn't really thinking about that
situation you just described you know
like I don't think a lot of black
Americans that I've been in conversation
with over over my life have been really
talking about paralytic white guilt this
the wave of communications in the past
several weeks has been really
fascinating um let me make it about me
yeah I was like here's the thing like is
so funny cuz all the white dudes are
freaking out right now trying to figure
out what to say what not to say and my
black friends are like relax man
yeah like we've been waiting for you
it's cool yeah
how do I get it right I was like
counting on you to get it right
don't worry like just chill out you know
join in yeah the whole paralytic idea of
getting a writer
I didn't even know you know like when
after the George Floyd killing when when
you know black when before we were
really aware and it was happening daily
right you know like our experiences our
understanding of the moment what was
setting in so when there was like so
much like white silence I was like oh
okay cool white white white people have
anything to say okay cool and it was
actually a real vacuum a real deafening
silence it was actually really
incredible because I was able to I was
able to just think about the life of
Ahmad our Barry Brown Taylor George
Floyd without so much noise you know and
I was able to reach out and connect to
like other black people in that space
and just have these emotional
connections and what were those
conversations like you know that they
were uncomfortable because you know you
really have to I mean like everybody has
divestment that they need to consider so
you really have to kind of like let go
of machismo or you like these kind of
like chauvinistic ideas of our own
vulnerability and fragility and so I
just reached out and just like honestly
I think it was like the Tuesday after
George Floyd
I just called and like texted like a lot
of black men in my life I wasn't like an
Instagram I wasn't you know doing much
except that and it wasn't then I was
just like saying that to my friends and
my family you know it was that I was
doing it to people that I respected from
a distance mm-hmm
I was reaching out to people that I know
didn't really like me too much and I
just wanted to like say and it wasn't
even cut and paste I was actually going
through and I was like reaching out to
someone and just saying like hey just
want to let you know for these qualities
I just wanna let you know and today that
I love you cuz I think that it was just
like my instinct spiritually emotionally
they're like black men needed to hear
black men black women need to hear it
every day of their lives but black men
you know the day after watching or the
day of watching video of this this man
getting killed you know over the course
of eight minutes and 46 seconds needed
to know that they were loved and so that
was like a really emotionally exhausting
process that I went through on that day
so that was it took a few days to
recover from that so then by the time
the weekend rolled around and I saw you
know like white women Yogi's were like
hosting zoom chats for people to examine
fragility then it was cool I was like Oh
white people got this white people just
gonna talk to each other they're not
gonna bother me at all so I'm good I was
like it went from like white silence to
like white people talking to each other
it was great that Monday hit that cat
that bell rang on Wall Street every
every black person's phone starts
ringing knocks I get on a plane and talk
to me on the podcast I was like Oh white
people white people are silent on this
that's terrible I'm angry but it's also
like a nice little respite from white
people ding ding ding ding ding the
phone was hot from like Monday 8:00 a.m.
like white people needed needed the
materials reviewed you know what I mean
so so or they need Knox to tell me that
I'm okay
yeah and I'm like that's not that kind
of guy like I'm not a month that's not
me so so that was like a process that
you know I was kind of awkwardly and
begrudgingly negotiating and then the
third week white people had it figured
out already so then I was like oh now
why people are like black square Tuesday
and companies like black people we've
got it figured out here's 10k here's uh
huh 40 million Mike cool you know what I
mean so it was really Swift the way the
fumblings of people's responses or
brands or responses to kind of this
tragedy yeah it is an awkward fumble
though because you know I found I'm
finding myself doing the same thing like
I said like I'm grappling without a
communicator
and and also you know getting honest
about diversity on my own platform like
I talked about this the other day like I
like to think that I've had a wide
variety of diverse voices on my podcast
but when I'm objective about it and I
measure it up against the five hundred
and twenty plus podcasts that I've had
it's predominantly white like I have a
lot of growth there right so what do I
do
well I get out you know my contact list
and I and I scour Twitter and I look for
interesting voices and then you know
you're the one who gets the phone call
among other people and that's weird too
like oh now I'm gonna call Knox and it's
cool and I'm glad that you're here and
it's awesome but like does that feel
like when you got that call from me were
you feeling like oh this is this is
somewhat opportunistic also you're gonna
mean like you know what I'm getting at
ah yeah I mean you can't you can't
overlook it you know I mean like as
Richard Pryor I've talked to rich since
we did that retreat you know like now
he's calling me you know but I mean you
know we're cool like I feel like the
bond that we have as as dudes and as
runners and athletes and writers and and
kind of like engaged humans on the
planet hey you're taking that call you
know but but I was thinking like that's
one idea to like reach out and like us
to connect but there's this movie Putney
Swope I don't know if you've ever seen
it but in a long time yeah right so
everybody go back and rewind this movie
because I keep thinking about it all the
time you remember the opening scene is
the kind of like Madison Avenue
all-white boardroom of the advertising
agency and the chairman of board has a
cardiac arrest and dies like on the
table yeah and so they have to go around
with the body on the table they go
around and do a vote for who's gonna be
the next chair there's one black guy
it's late 60s and they all do anonymous
vote and when it comes time to read the
votes
he
wins unanimously to be the next chair
and all the white dudes are enraged like
how did he do it first of all each white
dude voted for him because none of them
wanted another white dude to become the
chair and then he voted him for himself
so not only they mad that they all like
hood wing to each other
then they say like you voted for
yourself and he's like of course I was
the best man for the job
he gets up he says the speech and he's
like I just want to let you know it's
just gonna be a few small changes and
then the next scene is the boardroom
it's all brothers and afros you know
people are doing hair braiding at the
table and you know watch the film and
and just because you swap out the
boardroom and put all black people and
doesn't make it great they still you
know do shitty marketing campaigns for
black people it's just black people
doing the marketing so there's a good
good lesson there but I was gonna say
really in the spirit of this moment
another model is turning over your
podcast to me yeah and I take over so
what is Knox Robinson's podcast that
rich rule look like so right and I
started kind of like thinking about what
that was gonna be I was like I would
have to have a DJ you know kind of
playing it would have like music break
and I was like how would I what would
Knox Robinson do in the spirit of the
revolution like what would I do to
totally flip your podcast so that's the
other I like that that's another
proposition I'd let you do that yeah you
have seen people do that with Instagram
they're turning their Instagram accounts
over to diversity of voices and I think
that's really cool yeah so you know
anytime you want to come and do that you
might have to move out at Mexico City at
some point how long are you gonna be
there you think I'm working on something
special I'm you know yeah I'm working on
something special I'm bringing together
you know I'm building a training camp
with Herman Silva that Wow York City
Marathon ha winner and I'm working with
one of the greatest architects Michelle
Roach Kent who you know also in Mexico
City and so Michelle is going to kind of
create this amazing brudos architecture
structure
next to Herman Silva's training camp and
so we're working on that like rec
empowerment at home a treat center
that's very so that should be you know
ready you know at the end of this year
Wow so I'm really excited to to share
that obviously like this is gonna be
like a second home for you a second home
but I want it to be like a second home
for like a lot of people cuz I was
thinking about you know as we were
heading up to Tokyo Olympics and and how
some of our American elites you know I'm
thinking about it when I was a kid
looking up an elites you know Steve
Holman and Bob Kennedy and they're like
Titans to me now I'm older and I'm a dad
I'm thinking how these kids are living
and I was like oh these kids are
starving like these kids are like the
best runners in America and they're
broke right now we deal with brands so
we know how bad these deals are you know
make it like crazy little money and so I
was like oh I kind of want to have a
training center or I can just like throw
the keys to some of these great training
groups that are out there you know you
see them on Instagram and they're doing
amazing workouts dirt road and Boulder
but you're like are these guys living
like eight in a condo in Boulder yeah
like can I just like stuff yeah flag
stuff like you want to glamorize it when
we're stuck in our worlds you know in
our in our things but I just want to
throw the keys to like some folks and
just have people come out and train for
like six weeks and like you know super
cool see what it's like so yeah I just
wanted to be like a resource for for for
people kind of getting after their goals
in that kind of ways yeah I met Silva
when I did that event in Mexico cities
oh okay beautiful humble yeah I really
an incredible person and it's an he's so
still so engaged and so it's it's funny
to have kind of like ended up in this
bizarre friendship with him over the
past like eight or so years so to kind
of build this project with him along
with Michelle is really kind of coming
together of serendipitous energy yeah
have you seen this have you seen a
manual shows uncomfortable conversations
with a black man no oh
this is like blowing up the internet
yeah so he he played football at
University of Texas and was in the NFL
and now he's doing this series like
uncomfortable conversation for the black
man and he did his first one with
Matthew McConaughey oh okay I just like
exploded the internet yeah it's it's
cool cuz you know Matthew is the foil to
him and it's like is it should I say
black or african-american like it's very
it's very basic and yeah it's so
eloquent and like walking people through
like let's just you know get a few
things straight here you know because
the couple a couple listeners I know or
viewers who were seeing this are good
he's talking about me but yeah folks
have asked been asking me like capital B
or lowercase B so yeah yeah I mean you
know it's Eid I was writing blog posts
the other day and Isla and I thought
about that I was like is it black or is
it african-american like which one is it
you know there's like a lot of stuff
that like you know the the learning
curve is high for everybody itself is a
great Google search right because it's
like which newspapers and which media
organizations in the 20th century
decided to say colored Negro but then
black capital B what is the capital B
indicate versus lowercase so it's a
question of syntax and grammar that that
editors can weigh in on but it's also a
question of identity for a lot of folks
too so you know yeah language politics
is personal politics back on this thing
about a lie ship yeah I'm not sure we
ever got to the desert on that but I I'm
interested in what you know I want to
explore that a little bit more and also
kind of what the what the blind spots
are that you're seeing out there yeah
because I'm thinking about it a lot and
like again I'm not trying to be I'm
trying to like do white people's work
and like think about what a white Ally
should be I mean respect to other
brothers and sisters who are like Ally
coaches right now that that's valid you
know it's just not not my thing but
having had incredible relationships with
with with white folks you know over the
course of my life I keep thinking about
I keep thinking about this guy that I
trained with when I left New York City I
moved up to the woods on the banks of
the Hudson River his name's Mike
Solinsky yeah we talked about that a
little bit last time you
um he's never gonna see this so I can
speak freely yeah before he was on
Instagram I would write about him all
the time I called him the bus driver he
was driving a bus for the local school
district and I was just telling him all
like you're writing about his incredible
wildlife and his stories and his insight
I mean this guy they changed my life but
he was on an Instagram so it was like a
gift for a writer I could just be
writing about this dude and he would
never know now he's on Instagram and I'm
like so now he's on Strava know it's bad
now he's on Strava can't get away it's
bad I was like and I'll travel you know
when Strava gives you the alerts when
I'm that your course little segment is
you know you lost the course record or I
don't know what that's like because I
haven't held any of those that's that's
part of the the athletic experience that
I'm not familiar yeah well oh yeah
you're like direct hits of that no I was
living in the Hudson Valley they barely
get an Internet so um I'll be traveling
somewhere and I woke up and it's like I
just lost a course record to this dude
and I was like you don't know he's like
why what's that is like well you get an
email notification he's like what I was
like yeah you just never mind all right
but this guy over the course of time
that I was living in this tiny town and
the bacon banks of the Hudson was
incredible he was just the best training
partner consistent focused and you would
really have to work hard I mean if I've
known this dude almost ten years the
number of times we've kind of like
veered out of like non-training talked
have been few you know and I'm talking
about like when we were running
sometimes we're running through these
towns in upstate New York and we were
into this town next to ours Wappingers
Falls and I was like Wappingers Falls
isn't where this was the whole Tawana
Brawley incident Tawana Brawley incident
al Sharpton was up here and there was
like protests and stuff he's like yeah
bad times in town and so he couldn't
really pull this guy into
of any identity politics conversations
but he would come around and run he's
always good to be there with the work
out he's always ready for that that
Sunday long run this guy would get up
before our long run and he would go and
like put water out on the course yeah
over a 20-mile run and then come back
and then meet us and then run for like
three people you know that that's kind
of like my understanding of like serving
others and serving a friend and being an
ally so even in running you know you're
an ally and running doesn't necessarily
have to like be up on the New York Times
bestseller list but a person who's
respecting you as an athlete and
respecting you as another person and
definitely making sure that you're
afforded safe passage if you're like
moving moving through through space but
someone who has your back in that way
but then I think on like a social level
the other thing that I can't get over is
like as white folks are trying to tell
each other what an ally looks like and
as like you know trying to out ally yeah
I'll I'll I each other and then like a
super binary black and white and so like
you know Asians are trying to figure out
how they participate in it and they're
trying to like settle scores with white
people and they haven't necessarily been
historically the best allies with black
people so the whole thing is fraught and
I just think that like this isn't an
idea that's been vetted by the experts
but I think white allies got to look at
or like aspirational allies just got a
take a seat and like look at how black
people interact with each other you know
the mutuality the exchange the
information exchange the love exchange
that occurs black people are hard on
each other you know for sure but the the
bedrock of love and respect that has
been key through the survival and the
perseverance but also like the
one of our culture hmm is is key so you
know notebook is really gonna tell you
how to do that it's gonna provide some
insight but one thing I don't understand
about these lists is like there's very
little fiction you know I mean for me a
white ally has read Toni Morrison's Song
of Solomon you know like if black
culture is part of the of our American
culture and Toni Morrison won the Nobel
Prize for Literature in 1993 like
everybody here on Instagram talking
about a lie ship and all that if you
don't have Toni Morrison on your
bookshelf if you're just not reading our
Nobel laureate fiction then like what
are you doing with like all these
self-help books on the shelf you know
what I mean
so I really think you know yeah I was
like I need a short answer for what a
white Ally looks like and I'm like no I
like that just like Toni Morrison Song
of Solomon on your bookshelf cool that's
like an early early step you know yeah
it is interesting that that may be a
blind spot and yet black culture
predominates pop culture you know from
music to film right like that's I mean
well yeah I mean hip-hop is so dominant
sure now in terms of its cultural
influence right never and yet that
doesn't necessarily track to its
antecedents well no it does sadly right
because I mean no artwork does but the
putt the popular interest doesn't oh the
positive interest I was thinking and
like a more McCobb sense of the entire
wealth of you know the Americas was
predicated on black box so for us like
seeing hip hop and and and the legacy of
like blacks in America in the Americas
is is an essential link but uh yeah for
real you by the time it becomes pop
popular you sort of lose that original
essence right or or you think you do
right by it the more bricolage you put
on top of
foment yeah so your son's in New York
right yeah what are the conversations
that you're having with him right now
about what's going on yeah he's tough
you 666 Tina and everyone's like oh
that's gotta be terrible for him but I
can't understand I don't know if it's
like really hard to be 16 in a
quarantine lockdown
I'm a 16 year old daughter yeah it's
either bad but it's like it's rough
being 16 no matter what mm-hmm you know
so like if you're bare and shrunk it's
rough being barren Trump no matter who
your parents are if that's his parents
so I can't tell I can't tell if my son
how hard it can't you can't you can't
separate the angst of 16 with the
experience of a young black man growing
up around a lot of chaos yeah that's
yeah and also with me as his dad he's
definitely more even-tempered than I am
too so he's he's telling me to chill you
know what I mean so he is on the
precipice of like a huge time in his
life thinking about college but then
what does that even gonna look like so
I'm just kind of like it's it's weird
all the way around
he lives in Fort Greene and to think
that folks were burning a New York City
Police Department police cruiser like a
couple blocks from his house like that
was that block I lived on that block
when he was born I mean the day I got
home from the hospital where that
policeman is I walked to right on that
block with my son of my arms yeah and
like watch the Sun Rise had coffee and
like told him and you know my ancestors
said I was gonna be a better man that I
had been to that point we'll see what
how that turns out but and I started
running the next day so to see that
police van charred you know is uh is
actually like a weird kind of like
touchstone and my son still lives in the
neighborhood with his mom so that she's
been holding it down and yeah
it's interesting to see when what he's
gonna do with it what do you like what
do you want him to take away like how
does that from your perspective inform
you know how he matures into a man like
what do you want him to take away from
this experience as a young black man
growing up in America and in New York
yeah but I haven't really updated it
since I thought about what I wanted for
him as he was coming into this world and
I wanted I expect I demand that he be a
good citizen I mean all these kind of
like corny things that we came up with
about like helping the elderly cross the
street whether you believe in voting or
not but like civics you know I think
that the best examples of of our culture
no matter what your background is I
think that that's what I hope my son and
my daughter embody you know I think I
expect and demand that he's has an
engagement in the whole world and
thinking about our global community I
expect and demand that he you know cares
about others and is compassionate and
conscientious but at the same time as a
young man he's got to make his own way
and so if I've sort of obfuscated or or
made fraud my meandering progression
that in a way is is you know kind of
implying to him that it's an incumbent
on him as a young man to find his own
way you know it's interesting to kind of
think of how you raise your kids you
know um
when we were living in Brooklyn you know
taking him home from school one time
he's four or five and somebody comes
around the corner and like wanted to
sell like a Playstation under his jacket
like you know and I was like and in that
moment like how do you explain that to
your kid because my son's like
oh my god yeah we could have had a
playstation dad and I was like well do
you explain do you assume that it was
stolen do you explain you know what what
do you do and then at that moment he's
four and I was like am I gonna be the
kind of person who tells their
four-year-old that there's good people
in the world and bad people in the world
and that bad people steal and good
people don't and just in that moment I
was just like I gotta like be I got to
be truthful you know and and kind of
talk about how complicated it is to live
in Brooklyn you know where you know
whatever you're doing to make a living
is on a spectrum of morality in a way
and certainly for instance someone
selling weed in Brooklyn fifteen years
ago
in California in 2020 could be you know
an entrepreneur screw an entrepreneur or
you know I mean so even our morality
spectrum is so ill informed by sort of
arbitrary or self advantageous or
convenient the morality spectrum has to
be contextualized by the social you know
forces that compel a restriction of
opportunity yeah so we have to change
those social forces right like we can't
affect the spectrum you can't can't even
participate in the spectrum if the
sources are suspect right we got a
really dismantle those forces that
you're describing and that's the work
we're doing when we're talking about you
know dismantling white supremacy I mean
white supremacy is such a wild idea it's
such a wild phrase and I keep referring
back to this a police van that was you
know torched in in Brooklyn and I saw
the photo I'm in Mexico City thousands
of miles away and I see these young two
young black women fresh clothes style
and they're posing in front of the
police van
and one of the sisters is holding up a
sign that says [ __ ] white supremacy and
I swear it is like one of the most
inspiring images I've ever seen in my
life
you know and I mean I had a couple
friends black friends who were like ah
that's Jason cloud Oh kids these days
they'll say anything and I was like no
it's crazy that these girls these young
women could have done anything they
could have like done any pose you know
my sister's got poses for days and when
it came time for them to like take a
photo in front of this burning police
car they held up a sign that said white
[ __ ] white supremacy that's crazy
like you couldn't say [ __ ] white
supremacy six months ago people don't
even know what that means like white
supremacy wasn't even like a discussed
concept and so if if understanding white
supremacy as a concept is has entered
our national dialogue and we're able to
work on that that that just wasn't even
happening just a short time ago I mean
the fact that Miriam you know Webster
changed the definition of racism this
week oh they did I don't even know that
that's crazy you how did it change the
are it's too crazy it was like a sister
just woke up one day I guess she had
been emailing them I know and I think
the definition that they had was the
belief racism is the belief that
characteristics and all this kind of
stuff determine who you are as a people
racer for these concepts and she's like
this definition is off you know and she
kept emailing them in emailing him and
then after all the events that we've
seen around the world recently they
emailed their back and they're like you
know we took a second look at this
definition and you know it's not just
this errant belief in like race-based
characteristics like even the situating
of that definition is problematic you
got to think about what the sister was
doing because she must have just been
sitting around with white co-workers
like it's happening in every coffee
break room around the country wider
people like right there
yeah let me pull up the definition and
read it to you remember that remember
when people used to we'll look it up in
the dictionary the belief that you know
that that's not me so they changed it to
how did that what was the change the
change is like it's it's more complex
like it's like brings in again sort of
what we were just talking about in terms
of like the nuanced the nuanced forces
that affect a person's view of seeing
race in that way rather than just like
some erroneous view that if it didn't
apply to you you know it's almost like
it's almost like Buddhism right like
Buddhism doesn't care if you believe in
it or not it's just the way the world is
put together you know for Noble Truths
and and all that kind of stuff so I
think updating the definition of racism
and taking it away from this idea that
like it's an idea that exists out there
that a person can subscribe to or not
and if it doesn't if they think it
doesn't apply to them then they're
absolved of being a racist
it's like recognizing that racism is a
social force that is affecting people
rather than a belief that irrespective
of your individual perspective on it you
know just this couldn't think about like
the practicalities of how this was huge
yeah and it was just this one sister who
just was like Takuma making one phone
Webster like and yeah it was crazy so
that's wild it could open the dictionary
yeah like for every no then I was
realized I was like oh that's what was
going on she was like sick of like
working it radio trying not radio shack
but like sick of probably working on
these dudes was just like I'm not racist
look it up Wow the the imagery and the
filmmaking that's going on right now is
is so extraordinary yeah you know and
it's almost like a day doesn't go by
where there's a new clip of this person
doing that but he whether it's behaving
badly or behaving courageously and you
know it's so it's so impactful and
powerful and indelible the power of you
know these phones that we have in our
pocket to chronicle this moment
so comprehensively and the impact of
that on our kind of national and
individual psyche and I'm interested in
I think I already know the answer to
this but you know how that leaves you
like on some level this is this is not
new like this has been going on for a
long time but for whatever reason it's
entered our consciousness because of the
rapid-fire nature of these recent you
know tragic events that were were
depicted in a way that made them you
know irrefutable like we demanded that
we pay attention to what's happening and
when you hear about you know the debt
whether it's the definition of racism
and the dictionary getting changed or
people taking to the streets like
changes happening and there is this
sense that we are living in a very
historic moment of promise and
opportunity and personally that gives me
hope and I know there's people out there
like Donaghy C coats who are expressing
hopefulness around this I listen to a
podcast with him recently with Ezra
Klein in which he expressed that I mean
do you share that or how do you kind of
project into the near and far our future
about how this is gonna unfold
well Coates is an interesting example
because he actually sees his own work as
a pivot from the Obama era optimism
where Obama says the Obama said that the
the arc the moral arc of the universe
bends towards justice yeah yeah the
moral I think the moral arc of the
universe is long but it bends towards
justice right or eventually yeah like
that yeah Coates is like it bends for
it's confusion you know I mean and and
that's that's a scary concept but I
think that what we see in his work and
what I think we see in this moment now
is a falling of the scales from our eyes
and I think that this is an opportunity
for us to really see things as they are
you know and really grasp hold of that
and not what you know mainstream media
is telling us by the time it gets it but
what we're actually like what we know to
be
true and that's that's that is a leap of
faith right you know but I think that
this is our chance to see beyond the
speeches that politicians are making
this is our chance to think a little bit
beyond what our mainstream media is
telling us and what does it mean for us
and strangely this opportunity has been
a reset on so many levels but it's been
a reset on like my mindfulness practice
and going back to the beginnings of that
and then just thinking about the ways in
which a mindfulness practice helps us
just think of things more clearly you
know it's interesting you know you kind
of think that meditation is like about
become a guru and a mountaintop or
something like that but I've been
reading and hearing some things lately
that it's like it's not even about this
Nirvana state of an empty mind it's
actually about more practical than that
in some ways and it's about like being
able to navigate thoughts and like see
things clearly and I think that that's a
tremendous gift that that is at our
disposal right now to work through and I
think that kind of work on a personal
level is what's going to equip all of us
to kind of work our way through and yeah
that's what we're seeing in the comments
section right to take it from like a
spiritual idea down to like a super you
know absurd example but before you might
see all comments sort of unified but now
if you're seeing all these kind of
disparate voices you're seeing like the
fragmentation of people thinking their
way through it in the past few weeks you
know in 1992 rioting was bad or why
would these people burn their own
neighborhood well in Los Angeles it was
an update of 92 they weren't burning
their own neighborhood right it was like
a strategic move to burn not like
neighborhoods it the conversation that's
happening with white people about like
the difference between protesting
peaceful protesting looting and rioting
that's an interesting conversation to
have instead of just kind of like
watching your TV screen glow and I and
like kind of like making assumptions
write what you think it is without
understanding that that choices are
being made about which images you're
being presented and yeah and they're
being contextualized in a certain way
and that that happened to me though you
know like the day the day after
Minneapolis first started to burn I got
an Instagram and I saw this really wild
footage of someone just driving down the
road holding their phone out and was
just like block after block of
devastation like on a cultural level
pop-culture level I I couldn't couldn't
it was just like blocks and blocks and
then it was posted with like no
commentary but it was posted by this
amazing shop called repair lair I
followed him an interim because I think
I must've read an article about him in
Outside magazine and I was just cool I
think a cool young couple cool young
people who are have a business that
repairs outdoors gear you know I mean so
there's a sustainability mission there's
an access mission and all that kind of
stuff at the time I wasn't really
thinking about the provenance of the
handle so I was just like hey
disappointment follow fan of this
account I think it's problematic that
you're posting this you know I'm
disappointed that you were posted
without any context you know because
their followers were outdoor supporters
and so there was so much condemnation of
why would these people burn their own
stores and are you safe and I was like
ah man you're on the wrong side of
history this little judgmental on my
part but reacting in the moment and man
the owner really like got at me in the
comments you know like it was really
antagonistic and some of the other
people and I don't engage in social
media in terms of like going back and
forth with me more I just one cup of
coffee you know and kind of reacted and
so since then I've like opened up a
dialog with the owner with this woman
and just trying to like figure that
you know thinking about how I could
connect or we could connect and the
outdoors world could connect with the
rebuilding of urban devastation in
Minneapolis you know like where the
destruction of her shop is is just a few
blocks from where Brogan Graham lives
yeah you know and so how can we kind of
think about supporting small businesses
as we build back our cities and still
continue our mission of like
sustainability and access to the
outdoors and all that kind of stuff so I
really think that you know important
conversations bridging that gap and and
and reaching across that impasse you
know not only me acknowledging that
maybe I was kind of like applying too
much heavy pressure to someone who was
like fearful of losing their business
but also being able to double back
outside the chatter and make a
connection and then I'm just kind of
like among a lot of other things I'm
thinking about is how I can connect with
this woman in her business that like has
a great mission you know yeah that's
interesting I mean it's that second
piece I think that's impactful that ties
into the mindfulness so you you saw this
you got activated and despite your
mindfulness practice you found yourself
reactive but at least you were able to
understand that you were being reactive
and realized that there was actually an
opportunity here and to reach across and
and to try to you know develop a little
bit of Brotherhood or unity you know
where can we see eye-to-eye here even
though we may may be perceiving this
situation completely differently sure
yeah I mean because like you got a dance
with a girl that brung you you know in
so I was thinking how did I even get up
there in the first place how was i
following ended up on following I was
like I'm not even here for this convo
like and I only got pulled back in when
she kind of kept talking at me and I had
to had to come back and be like he's
still talking I thought about it again
empathetically and then I was just
calling Brogan I was like yo this
business is right around the corner from
you
you're the founder of November project
like let's as he has he that's cool I've
been I've been talking to him a little
bit - yeah you know just getting his
boots on the ground perspective on
what's happening it's amazing because um
yeah
again I'm not doing any any white dudes
work for like all allies are equal but
some are more equal than others I am NOT
here there I'm not agree the title this
podcast is gonna be I am NOT here to be
your white knight here Oh black black
Ally for a white guy is different from
how a white guy gotta be allied to a
black dude so go Brogan it's been a
little light I've been just kind of like
hey yeah um he said you those videos
yeah that's how he communicates I'm
sorry so you see one pop-up and you're
like God I like video back yeah you
can't be around your lady like now it's
a weird love affair with this guy who's
like wearing some wild clothes uh-huh
but yeah he was getting a little
pressure there's a a real strong brother
real strong voice in New Orleans who was
just like going ham a November project
for co-opting Ann Arbor yeah and I know
they found themselves in a little bit of
a crosshairs but yeah and I was like hey
Brogan like I didn't even wait in over
there I didn't just kind of like yeah
light em up brother like cool double
back to Brogan like hey be good that's
kind of gradually they were like even if
I'm not helping him I'm like listening
or even just tapping him on the shoulder
that like hey you're the founder you've
moved on in your life and you raising
the kid I'm raising a kid but like this
is like just dig on this conversation
he's like yeah cool and then three weeks
later his entire neighborhood is burning
like that's a wild kind of thing I was
like hey let's catch up sometime and
like talk about represent black
representation in November project yeah
yeah like three weeks later he's like
cushion
so yeah shout out to their lane they
never yeah love for Brogan yeah you sent
me a t-shirt
he made well I I I cajoled him in
descending making me want and sending it
to me because he was doing it on
Instagram but it says it's those hands
spray-painted t-shirts that he makes
yeah but it says zoom calls summer camp
yes just as painful as a new project and
I'm sure that's that's crazy I don't
understand why people want to be in
November project anyway black black
people complain and I was like it your
arms are sore like why if it's not
representative like that's cool like
just something that's fine November
project is hard it is hard it's like
I've only done one not all right same
that's what I'm saying I was like Brogan
let's just be friends because I never
come into your thing so when black
people are mad about it I want to pull
to the side like letting you know what
you don't want to do that anyway alright
man well let's uh let's land this plane
how do we end this I mean you know I
think it would be good to just recap
maybe just share you know some final
parting thoughts about you know how we
move forward in the best way and you not
not to harp on this ally ship thing but
I really do want to you know use this
platform you know for good and and and
to you know be part of the solution to
this problem and I just want to explore
every possible way that I can do that
and having you here to speak to that has
been super helpful to me so thank you
for that and you know maybe just share a
couple quick quick thoughts to round it
out yeah I mean I know I'm wildly
discursive all over the place but I just
I keep I keep coming back to this idea
of love so I know that's super obvious
and basic and people talked about it
from time but a Barbara's best friend
say that it was weird
every time he would like leave from
hanging out he would say like I Love You
Man and he wouldn't leave until they
said it and he's doesn't like young
brothers sitting around in rural Georgia
at the car wash
even work you know and like that's like
a really insane and rigorous process
practice to do so when I called up all
these brothers and told them I loved
them it was like rigorous from Mayan it
was it was tough you know um to reach
out and man for all the mistakes that
I've made and then I'm gonna continue to
make as soon as I walk out this door I
just want to keep thinking about love
and and I and I and I wish that I would
hope this would be a moment for people
to reset and reflect on what that is you
know and for all the little
microaggressions that we engage in or
all the times that we take around
chitchat and any time we just you know
serve as a detractor to someone else for
no reason all these things are adding up
to this giant feeling of of psychic pain
that you can just feel whether you're
feeling it in America's cities or you're
feeling it in a Matar burries killers
like how abject were these guys that
they went into like seek-and-destroy
mode you know what I mean like manat too
early to kind of think about the
spiritual poverty the imaginative
poverty that racists feel you know what
I mean
so if we can kind of at least consider
what an ethic of love looks and feels
like if we can just kind of like reset
and refer back to those basic civics
that maybe we thought we
gonna pursue as we got older that's
really what I'm thinking about a night
and I'm thinking about that honestly in
like a really corny kind of social media
way like it's okay to be like a white
Ally with you know 1047 followers and
like here's the list and you're like
banging on at white people but if then
you're like going and getting in the DMS
and like detracting from someone else
mm-hmm if you're the purveyor of
suspicion or innuendo or you know kind
of things like you got to think if our
own white supremacy is uninvestigated
until very recently and that's black
people i black people have a social
sickness that we've inherited from 400
years of experience in this country so
everybody is is on the docket right now
to investigate our own internalized
white supremacy every time you drag in
somebody and everyone you're engaged in
a little bit of chitchat every time
you're sort of kind of like
appropriating and every time you're
doing all the little things you know
it's not just racist jokes that you're
kind of telling you know they're in the
break room it's like all the little
small things that are up for
investigation like the world doesn't
become any less boring because you're
not like the funny person tell racist
jokes and your world doesn't become any
less interesting when you kind of like
fall back from engage engaging and
gossip and innuendo you know so I just
think that for me that's what I've been
trying to consider and that's individual
work you're not gonna get a pat on the
back for that okay if you stop that no
one's gonna know you know like if you
stop being a racist the only people who
are gonna know are you're racist friends
so I'm sorry to tell all the allies the
aspirational allies out there
it ain't no medals uh-huh you know what
I mean it ain't no podium kind of thing
you see even the white dude was on there
with the podium and with Giancarlo's and
he just they didn't even give him a
glove whatever he's like it's two gloves
bro
you know I mean everyday you know it's
really think about white people every
time you post a photo of John Carlos or
an Tommy Smith there's always a white
guy from New Zealand who got a chump and
like unless we forget so yeah I guess I
I guess I just want to kind of think
about that with like a namasthe a type
of vibe of things you know mm well
that's beautiful
speaking of appropriation yeah shoutouts
oh yeah all those Hindus out there yeah
hurry up so we have me right I Love You
Man thank you so much yeah I appreciate
your openness and honesty and
vulnerability today it meant a lot to me
that you came all the way out here to
share with me so I appreciate you and I
look forward to spending more time with
you man so thank you thank you very much
for this opportunity just to kind of
like share in that energy yeah it was
good man there's good you feel all right
yeah I feel excellent good yeah if
people are digging on knocks easiest
best way to find them at first run on
Instagram is that where you want to
direct people anything else going on you
want to let people know about no man
it's just a big things are kind of
coming up as you know kind of building
this place in Mexico is anything strong
kind of move into some some new projects
to share with folks to kind of
participate in these ideas that we've
shared too so I've definitely been using
this time to kind of go back to my own
drawing board so I'm really looking for
two things from here on out to share
yeah cool man
thank you all right thank you peace
plants namaste
[Music]
you